CHRIS BROADFOOT: Are we on?
Hi, welcome to another
Google Maps API
Developer Office Hours.
Today we'll actually be talking
about the Places API.
And I'm joined by, to my
right, Andrew Bennetts.
ANDREW BENNETTS: Hi.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Software
engineer.
And Marcelo Camelo.
MARCELO CAMELO: Hello.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Who is the tech
lead for the Places API.
So you may have seen, this
morning we launched Place
Photos and Radar Search.
If you haven't seen that, go
and check out the Google
Developers blog.
And I'll show you that
in a moment.
But first, we have some news on
the Places API challenge.
All the entries are in.
Thank you for submitting
your apps.
We've had some great apps.
I just had a quick look before
I came down here.
And we'll be displaying those
for public voting on the 12th
of December.
So next week you'll be able to
vote on all the apps that
people have submitted.
And I think early next year
we announce the winners.
So, without further ado, let's
talk Radar Search and Photos.
So--
MARCELO CAMELO: You
want me to--
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Tell
me a little bit
about photos, maybe.
MARCELO CAMELO: Let me answer
with Radar Search.
I'll let Andrew talk about
Photos, because he worked
directly on that.
So the idea with Radar Search
was to be able to return more
than just the 60 results that
we commonly return.
A lot of developers ask for the
ability to do stuff like a
heat map, with being able to
show which areas the greatest
concentration of a certain
type of business.
Or simply doing a real estate
website, and you're showing a
specific property, and you want
to be able to show every
single grocery shop, or every
single school around the
specific location with a much
broader viewport than just the
one you usually are able to
show with 20 results.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So we actually
do have pagination as
well, right?
MARCELO CAMELO: Not on--
CHRIS BROADFOOT: On the
regular search.
MARCELO CAMELO: On the
regular search, yes.
So the pagination on regular
search is more aimed towards
you having a scrollable
list, ideally an
infinite scrollable list.
But it only linked to 60
results in page of 20s.
And the idea is that Radar
Search is initially we offer
200 results.
And, depending on how it goes,
it can even offer more.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So if I want
more detailed results, I use
pagination for search.
But if I want a huge amount--
and I think it's just the
location and a place reference
that comes--
MARCELO CAMELO: You get just a
location, so they can show a
point where the place is.
And you get a reference,
so you can--
maybe on the user click---
display more details
about the place.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Cool, great.
I can see some great
walk score sorts of
applications for that.
So definitely some
cool things.
And so all the filters
are available
for the Radar Search?
MARCELO CAMELO: Yes.
You can search by keyword,
which is really nice
differentiator of
the Place API.
So you can do search like we did
on the demos, just saying,
nice views.
It's not really a categorical
search.
But it will return you places
that either advertise
themselves as having nice views,
or people have written
reviews saying that
it has nice views.
You can also use type search.
So you can search for bars or
restaurants, or any of the
types that we support.
You can also--
what other features
do we have?
ANDREW BENNETTS: It's all the
usual types and keywords and
categories.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah, I think
one of the features that
people don't use enough
is the keyword search.
I think that's a really
awesome feature
of the Places API.
So if you haven't used it
before, it searches over of
all of the data that Google
has about a place--
so reviews, the categories
and the tags that
are provided by place.
MARCELO CAMELO: Even sometimes
the actual content on the
place's official web page.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Oh, wow.
OK.
So it searches over things that
you can't even get back
on the Places API.
We wouldn't be able
to do that.
OK, so let's go over to a
demo of Radar Search.
So this is on our Google
Geodevelopers blog.
So this was posted
up earlier today.
So you can see here we're using
the heat map feature of
the JavaScript API to show the
nicest views in Sydney.
So if I zoom in--
I can't zoom in.
So you can see they're are all
situated around the harbor,
lots around Darling Harbour.
So this is quite an accurate
look at the best views in
Sydney, really.
This is another one
of my favorites.
So essentially you can look
for Chinese restaurants
anywhere, in any city, and
you can figure out
where Chinatown is.
So you can see this quite
accurately locates Chinatown
in San Francisco,
which is great.
ATMs in Manhattan.
So I'm not sure exactly what
this one is indicating.
MARCELO CAMELO: This pretty much
indicates that you have
ATMs all over the place.
There isn't a ATM suburb
in Manhattan.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: And
clothing stores in
Paris, this one's great.
So you can see here, also, that
the search is limited by
the bounds.
So it's actually the bounds
of the initial search.
You can see you don't
get back any
results outside the bounds.
So you can quite nicely limit
the results to just the area
that you're interested about.
MARCELO CAMELO: On this specific
demo, we've chosen to
display the results as a heat
map, but you're not actually
limited to it.
You can use whatever you want.
The other option just
to show results of
points or even markers.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Another
thing-- are the results
returned in any sort of order?
MARCELO CAMELO: Just
from the 20.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: OK.
So we're joined by Justin,
down in the Hangout.
So Justin is joining us
from Mountain View.
He's the product manager
for Places.
Hi, Justin.
JUSTIN CHU: Hello, how
are you guys doing?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: We
can't hear you.
Are you?
JUSTIN CHU: I'm not muted.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: We have the
local sound turned off.
OK, so how excited are you
about these launches?
JUSTIN CHU: So excited.
No, we've been working really
hard on these things.
MARCELO CAMELO: Stop jumping
up and down, man.
JUSTIN CHU: We've been working
really hard on these things
for a while now.
And we're super pumped to get
these apps to developers, so
they can make their
applications even
prettier and better.
So yeah, props to you guys.
Obviously Andrew and Marcelo
sitting there, have been
working so hard on
these things.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: I believe
these are two of the most
requested features
at the moment.
ANDREW BENNETTS: More results
and photos, yeah.
JUSTIN CHU: Absolutely, yeah.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So on that
note, if you're interested in
having a new feature in the API,
we definitely listen to
that feedback.
So go and file your feature
request on the issue tracker.
There's links from the
documentation.
The most popular ones definitely
catch our interest,
and we try to work on those
as much as possible.
So let's talk about Photos.
ANDREW BENNETTS: Let's.
So we now return photos as part
of our results in the
Places API.
So on searches you just
get a single photo.
And when you look up
the details for a
place, you get 10 photos.
They give them back
as [INAUDIBLE]
like place references.
And you can fire off a request
to actually get the
pixels of the photo.
So it gives you photos of the
place taken by Google users
[INAUDIBLE]
pictures that you would find
on Google+ Local, and that
[INAUDIBLE]
Places API.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Great.
ANDREW BENNETTS: Make it much
more visually appealing
summary of the place in your
application, because you can
show a picture of it.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So who would
use this kind of feature?
Is it the searching kind of app
so that they can display
some photos?
Or as a business owner, would
I use this to display photos
of my store?
ANDREW BENNETTS: I would think
it's more the former.
If you're a business owner,
you probably already have
photos of your own.
You don't need to
ask us for them.
Although, you might want to see
the user generated photos
that have been provided
to Google.
So a bit of that.
But mainly I think it's--
we'll see what people
do with it.
But I would expect that it'll
be people wanting to show it
in their search results, and
show a little teaser photo.
And then you can click
through and find out
more about the place.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So it's
probably worth noting that
both of these features are
available through the web
service and the JavaScript
API.
So obviously, the demos in the
blog post are using the
JavaScript API.
But you can do all of that
with the web service.
So it's great for mobile
application.
For example, you can still show
the photos quite easily.
So if we switch over to the
demo, let's have a look at
some photos.
So here we're using the
Places autocomplete.
This is actually the search
box, which lets you do
unstructured queries
like, pizza.
Or if I said P-I-Z-Z, it's going
to suggest to me, pizza.
So I can say pizza-- any--
It's going to suggest
me something.
So I can look for pizza near
Sydney, for example.
So we're actually just getting
the photos and putting them
straight onto the map as
markers, which is quite cool.
So you can get a quick view
at all of these results.
ANDREW BENNETTS: Yes.
At this point, the demo has
just done a search.
And so it's just got
the one photo.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So what's
another good one?
Maybe--
ANDREW BENNETTS: I
like meat pie.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Meat pie, OK.
So meat pies.
Let's have a look up here.
This is my favorite
pie shop, up here.
ANDREW BENNETTS: Does your
favorite pie shop
not have any photos?
You should upload some.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: That's
quite sad.
Pie in the Sky in Berowra,
by the way, awesome pies.
ANDREW BENNETTS: There's always
good old Harry's Cafe
de Wheels in Potts Point.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Great.
So we've got this little light
box that's popped up.
It's just pulling
down the photos.
Really straightforward
to implement.
So you can add some great
variety into your apps using
this feature.
So any other details on this?
ANDREW BENNETTS: So you can
request the photo in any size,
up to the size of the
photo we provide.
You can say, actually I
only want that maximum
400 width or height.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So I think
we're actually doing that
[INAUDIBLE].
ANDREW BENNETTS: We're getting
the photo and saying that we
just want the little
thumbnail.
And then we want it to fit
within the fixed size of the
light box there.
MARCELO CAMELO: I think they
were talking about either max
height or max width.
So it's really easy to make it
fit into a pre-defined grid or
a pre-defined box.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: And I believe
there's some attributions that
need to be shown as well?
That's the only limitation
on this setup?
ANDREW BENNETTS: Just like on
Place responses in general has
an HTML attributions field,
this also has HTML
attributions as a field
on the web service.
And so you just have to show
a little bit of HTML, so it
credits back.
Basically, which user uploaded
the photo, or which
source it came from.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So if you'd
like to find more about these
two features, definitely go and
checkout our Places API
documentation.
You can get to that through
the blog post that's on
googlegeodevelop
ers.blogspot.com.
So check that out.
Or you can look at the Google+
post that was posted earlier
this morning.
So that's an overview of Place
Photos and Radar Search, two
of my favorite features.
JUSTIN CHU: Mine too.
MARCELO CAMELO: I bet you
say that to everyone.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: I do.
I say that about all the APIs.
ANDREW BENNETTS: You just
love APIs so much.
CHRIS BROADFOOT:
I do love APIs.
So anything else happening in
Places land, other than the
Places challenge?
MARCELO CAMELO: Heaps
of stuff.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Any cool apps
that you've seen recently?
MARCELO CAMELO: Cool apps.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Justin,
do you have any input?
JUSTIN CHU: There was a recent
blog post on, I think,
Geodevelopers blog about QS,
a quick street view, which
essentially uses both the Street
View API as well as the
Place API autocomplete.
And essentially it was a super
awesome demo of how--
virtually moving through the
world at a fast pace.
As you can see in this demo,
it's just so much fun.
Knowing that I can go to any
place in the world at any
moment in time, with the Places
API service the Street
View service is super
powerful.
And I definitely wasted way too
much time on this, maybe
even at work, too.
But don't tell Andrew
or Marcelo that.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Let's
have a look at that.
So this is, indeed, on the
Geodeveloper blog.
So this is qsview.com.
Start typing an address.
Where do you live?
ANDREW BENNETTS: Funny.
Funny.
MARCELO CAMELO: Try Newport.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Newport.
MARCELO CAMELO: Somewhere
else.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: How about
NSW, because--
JUSTIN CHU: Type slower so that
people can see that it's
actually doing Street
View queries as
you're typing, as well.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Sorry,
my internet is
slow, for some reason.
So if I just type N.
JUSTIN CHU: That's
not going work.
So keep going.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: N-E-W-T--
oh, that looked like
an indoor inside
the New Orleans airport.
How do I get into that?
P.
OK, so this is some
guy's house.
Newport Road in [INAUDIBLE].
That's an awesome name for
a town, by the way.
So Newport Beach.
Is that getting into
Street View?
What am I doing?
That's picturesque.
JUSTIN CHU: It's very nice.
Yeah.
ANDREW BENNETTS: That's
pretty cool.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So now
we're finally at
Newport, New South Wales.
Yeah, that's indeed Newport.
But we want the beach,
don't we?
ANDREW BENNETTS: Always.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: That's
not the beach, is it?
MARCELO CAMELO: Well, that
would be as good--
that's just down the street.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: What
else would be cool?
Let's see if there's Mrs.
Macquarie's Chair.
Look at that.
ANDREW BENNETTS: Such
a nice spot, there.
Awesome.
Anything else?
MARCELO CAMELO: Not that
I'm allowed to
disclose at this moment.
ANDREW BENNETTS: I'd expect
eventually when the Grand
Canyon will be in
there somewhere.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So yes, next
mashup, QS view with Places
Radar Search, so you get all the
markers inside the thing.
That would be awesome.
JUSTIN CHU: Wow.
Yeah, I agree.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: A
challenge to you.
ANDREW BENNETTS: Challenge
[INAUDIBLE].
CHRIS BROADFOOT: OK.
Well, that's it for this week.
Stay tuned.
Go to
developers.google.com/live/maps
for upcoming GDL events.
And we'll see you next time.
ANDREW BENNETTS: Thank
you, Chris.
JUSTIN CHU: Thanks, Chris.
Thanks, guys.
ANDREW BENNETTS: See
you, Justin.